ukraine and russia are set to hold their
first face-to-face peace talks in more
than two weeks in istanbul joining us is
lord ricketts former permanent
undersecretary at the foreign office and
former british permanent representative
to nato hello to you thanks for joining
us on the programme this morning let's
talk about that poisoning first of all
alleged poisoning that the americans are
pouring a bit of cold water on it but
there is um you know previous obviously
from russia on poisoning people how
concerned should those taking part in
the peace talks be
i think they'll want to be very careful
indeed i mean we don't know what
happened it's quite mysterious
the problem is it could well have
happened because as you say the russians
have a long track record a kind of
morbid fascination with poisons and
chemical weapons so it is entirely
possible that somebody made an effort to
disrupt this informal mediation which is
i think what abramovich others were
trying to do so yeah i'm sure the
ukrainian negotiators in turkey and
indeed the turkish hosts will be being
extremely careful
yeah what's your advice to them people
taking part in peace talks with the
russians
well i i think
depend on your turkish hosts i think
today this is an initiative by president
erdogan i'm sure he will do everything
possible to keep everybody safe at the
venue but it is
a very very depressing conclusion that
you can't trust
russian negotiators and sit down with
them without worrying that there might
be some awful poisoning to be done what
um sort of steps would you take my lord
if you were taking part in peace
negotiations with face to face with the
russian entourage
i think i'd stick with the turkish
supplied
nibbles and water and stay off anything
else
a very good advice um talk to me about
uh president zielinski he uh was talking
i think on sunday night and uh he says
he's now willing to discuss neutral
status in exchange for peace how should
we interpret that
i think everybody wants this terrible
war to be over and we'd all love to
think that negotiations could produce a
breakthrough soon in the ceasefire and
i've absolutely no doubt that president
zielenski and the ukrainian side are
totally sincere but i'm really wary of
the russians here i don't honestly see
that the conditions are there for a
meaningful ceasefire
i think it's brave of president
zielinski to face up to the fact that
ukraine is not going to join nato
anytime soon he's interested in security
guarantees from the major powers and a
neutral status of ukraine possibly with
the right to join the eu
all these are important but they're
frankly secondary issues the key thing
is what happens to this territory that
russian forces have occupied i do not
believe that putin will be willing to
give up places like mario paul once they
do hold it firmly that's on the corridor
between the east which russia already
controls and the south and the crimean
peninsula i'm afraid his minimum
objective is to hold the territory that
he's now occupied
that requires ukraine to accept
effectively the partition of their
country and i just find it very hard to
imagine that any ukrainian government
could do that so i'm pretty skeptical
about the outcome of these talks
although it's a good thing people are
talking yeah even though the alternative
is the pictures that we've just been
looking at where parts of ukraine are
literally being bombed into oblivion
peace talks mean that both sides have to
give
yes they do
but they mean that ukraine would have to
be prepared to give up large slices of
the country
um which would be a kind of reward for
russian
conquest and occupation
i think it's perhaps more likely that at
some point the fighting will diminish
that there'll be some sort of truce and
a uneasy partition across a line of
separation neither side accepting that
is the outcome
that might
be a help for ukrainian citizens and
enable humanitarian help and so on to
them but it will be unstable and it will
guarantee that fighting will flare up
again in the future i don't want to
predict that but i think that's probably
more likely than a signed and sealed
peace deal any time in the foreseeable
future
diplomacy all important in peace talks
especially when you're dealing with a
country like russia how helpful was
president biden's comments at the
weekend weekend when it seemed that he
was suggesting that regime change in
russia was the only option
well i think he'd done extremely well on
this visit to europe he'd had a series
of summits in brussels i think which
he'd played brilliantly i think the
alliance feels stronger as a result
personally i think that remark about
effectively meaning regime change in
moscow was a mistake
because i think we need to keep the
focus on ending this war
and leave the future of president putin
to the russians i think putting russian
president putin in a corner feeling that
the objective of the west is to oust him
will only make things more difficult and
i know that his comments have been um
kind of corrected the sense of perhaps
went going a bit further than he
intended in those remarks
i think the real thing is to get this
war over uh and i think declaring our
objective is to house president putin is
a mistake okay my lord it's always good
to talk to you thank you for sparing the
time we do appreciate it
thank you
thank you